I want to start with a sincere
congratulations on the crown uh I think
the show is going to be a hit I'm
confident good well listen fingers
crossed because I didn't sign up to be
in a turkey let's face it
things about the crown which is just um
when I watch it it's just every aspect
of the production from the lighting to
the acting to the scripts like there's
no weak link what is it actually what is
it actually like behind the scenes
because you've worked on many projects
and it just seems like this is just
another level to be honest it is another
level and and I have worked on many many
projects over many many decades it is
unlike any other it's like it's it's as
if every single department is at the
very top of their game
um the attention to detail is
mind-blowingly phenomenal and that suits
me down to the ground because I'm I want
every eye dotted and every T no every
what's it every dot your eyes and cross
your t's yes I want all of that done and
they do it absolutely with knobs on on
this production it's quite exceptional
and then of course on top of that not
only do we have amazing sets that the
design 19 build but we also then go to
these sometimes we film in these
extraordinary stately homes and you're
acting and there's a real Rubens on the
wall behind you you know it it's it's
very very very very brilliantly done and
I always thought that watching it the
shots you know that they they just do it
so well so obviously you then kind of
think right I'm really mustn't let the
side down well I'm curious what it's
like as an actor when you are not only
playing a real person but you're also
inhabiting a character that has been
played by two other people in previous
Seasons what is it like for you stepping
into the role
um and just do you know what I mean
because it's I know exactly what you
mean I think that I think that uh
you have to put the other performances
aside because it's not help obviously I
watched them and marveled and enjoyed
them hugely what those two actresses did
with Margaret was phenomenal but that is
can't be my source my source has to be
um the real Margaret and the other part
of your question is that as actors and I
do a lot of theater work you know you're
always playing parts that other actors
have played and it's uh oh I'm always
pleased if I've never seen another actor
do it because
you it can feed into you in a subliminal
way that you maybe don't want it to and
what's the point I've been employed to
do my version of this part and obviously
I've we have to have the cost change on
the crown every two seasons because all
the characters are getting older so
um yeah my source was really Margaret
um and there's so much to find out about
all of the characters and then and you
have to absorb that let it go and then
my job becomes as it is on any job I do
to play the script and the words and the
emotions of what's in front of me I will
say that I had an opinion of the royal
family prior to watching the crown and
watching what Charles and everyone have
gone through I do have a different
opinion because of the show and I'm just
curious if your own opinion has shifted
being involved with the series and do
you have like a new appreciation for
what they've gone through behind the
scenes or if it's changed you at all
well I don't know that it's changed me
but it's it's you know it's obvious that
of course we look at these people
through a very public lens that's our
normal view of them and through world
events and and uh uh British events
but of course they're far more there's
they're far more complex than that we
are all unbelievably complicated human
beings and they may be royal but they
are individually complicated human
beings that are going through all the
kinds of emotions that you and I go
through that everyone goes through in
their lives you know love loss of Love
self-doubt
Myriad things so I think what the crown
does very beautifully is put the
microscope on them as human beings so it
humanizes them I don't want to give
spoilers for the season I've seen the
entire season but you have a very meaty
bit with Timothy Dalton and the previous
relationship with Peter and um what was
it like for you reading that script and
seeing the emotions you were going to be
portraying because it's really tying
back to the very beginning
yes well great I mean that's why I do my
job that's what I want to do get get to
the nitty-gritty of of of uh of
Margaret's emotions and what's um what's
making her tick you know there's a woman
who's endured
um relatively speaking a lot of pain
she's been through a lot she's made a
lot of sacrifices and she's not quite
had the life she expected or in terms of
um love and
um relationships so of course that is
just
um that's that's meat to me as an actor
I know that uh you guys are filming the
final season right now
um what what has it been like is it uh
can you just talk about what it's been
like filming the final season
well you know the scripts are they're
not going to disappoint their their
wonderfully written by Peter Morgan
um you know the the complications of the
family continue and uh you you know you
get an insight into uh all of the family
but obviously speaking from my
perspective as Margaret you know you get
to see what her final few years how they
were lived out and what she went through
and
um yeah how how it's very touching
there's some very uh there's some very
emotional scenes to come inevitably with
what everybody knows happens who was the
most excited of your friends and family
when you booked this role
oh that's an interesting question
um
wow uh
well there was there was a there was a
girlfriend that I told and she but I
swore her to see Chrissy and she did
very well she didn't tell anybody
um but she was incredibly excited about
and my you know my family were as well
but yeah we had to keep it quiet for a
very very very long time
um a very long time because I knew him
almost two years before we started that
I was going to play her so um yeah it's
the best kept secret I've ever kept last
question for you if someone has actually
never seen anything that you've done
before what is the first thing you want
them watching and why oh for God's sake
were you up all night thinking of that
that's a really hard question
um oh
that's like saying what what's my
favorite Joe what's the job I think oh
my God there's too many I mean I've done
two great players lots of great plays
but some plays that really have stayed
with me hey I did Long Day's Journey in
tonight I did ghosts to Great plays
great writing
um I'm I'm I know I'm going to be very
um fond of Margaret and very sad to say
goodbye to Margaret when I stopped
playing her I mean it's it's been
enormous and it's been a privilege and a
real treat to work on this series but
you know I my work with Paul Thomas
Anderson my many work many films with
Mike Lee you know there isn't it great
that I can say lots of the jobs I've
done are up there
um I mean there's probably a couple of
duffers along the way but we don't need
to mention those
sure on that note I just want to say
congrats I wish you nothing but the best
and great season thank you so much very
kind of you